hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going over by far the
biggest in most intense amalgamation of
their light the page on fire material
from throughout all of fujimoto's
Chainsaw man this stuff that happens
throughout this part of this story is
just utterly unparalleled like we have a
bunch of the strongest individuals from
outside of Japan all flying in to try
and take out dingy in this marineford
type battle that takes place throughout
the streets of Tokyo and like oh my Lord
it just doesn't even stop there as no we
actually make our way to the Demonic
land of hell where all of the Devils who
aren't currently on Earth reside just
before we do get in this absolute
Beatdown though if you want to watch
more full series explained arcs or just
straight fights then smash that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my content to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of it sit back and relax as all
of your favorite characters end up dying
but as this part of the story starts out
we actually get a little bit of
background kind of on all the characters
that are going to be playing their H
like on individual part and this kind of
beat down that is going to be coming up
so starting off off we actually fly all
the way over to America we're there a
trio of part-time devil Hunters sit and
discuss their new job killing dingy and
returning his body to the US in exchange
for 2 million of those beautiful
American buckaroos the youngest man Aldo
expresses a fear of dying however as
talked down by the other two reminding
him that the three of them all Brothers
survived the gun Devils Onslaught as
they prepare to leave for Japan the
leader Sato refers to them as immortal
elsewhere in a forest a woman and a
young man named tolka hunts a fox as he
shoots the fox the woman asks if he felt
like he'd taken the fox's life but the
man explains that he did not as he skins
the animal she asks him again and again
he says no as he cooks it and serves it
to her she asks again once more and yet
again he denies it the woman then
explains that they will be going to
Japan and doing the same to a young 16
year old boy named dinji The Man
referring to the woman as Master agrees
hoping to earn the woman a retirement
due to her short life span meanwhile in
China the hell is siki siki fun time
takes place between a woman named Quan
XI and a harem of I guess you could say
friends as they start nutting a man
arrives requesting her to take the job
of capturing dingy the chainsaw devil
and as a reward she can ask for any wish
after Consulting her group she demands
basic human rights and in education for
all of them at the same time makima with
kashibe expressing concern over her and
her harem's abilities as they talk
makima states that the biggest concern
is that of the Assassin Santa Claus from
Germany yo ho ho W is thought to have
died of old age the two are still
cautious as kashibe confirms his
abilities could likely outmatch them
elsewhere in Germany a government agent
approaches an old man on a bench and
informs him of the mission to hunt dingy
in return the man asks for four children
three for a devil contract and one for
pleasure wait what the what the is
does he mean by that like bro chill yo
like calm down meanwhile alone in his
room dingy lies watching TV sadly
wondering why his heart is so desired
and also while the trip was canceled not
even sadness Archie affectionately sits
on him explaining that the trip was
merely postponed not canceled and that
if they're able to damage their
opponents enough then the enemy will
Retreat allowing dingy to return to his
life as normal dingy considering the
idea instead decides to kill all of his
enemies so that he can finally have his
vacation stepping forward and now at the
park both dingy and power eat snacks
while watching some birds and talking
about whether it's okay to eat the still
living Ducks dingy accidentally drops
his food but as he goes to pick it up
and eat it he is stopped by a devil
Hunter named kusakabe and then chastised
by him kusakape warns him of Dooms and
food poisoning but dingy grows more
frustrated as obviously our meds from
the gutter akian Angel Yoshida and Tama
Oaky also all agree that eating the food
would just be straight up stupid however
the forever ignorant dingy quickly
gobbles it down anyway and a flashback
we see the group all introducing
themselves makima explains to dingy that
they alongside another Trio of Agents
will be his personal security
kusakabe attempts to express his
authority over dingy but has met without
boys typical sarcasm and yawns elsewhere
the Hunter's tendo corros and Subaru or
take Ziggy breaks questioning why they
can't simply hide dingy and as human
form Subaru explains that the other
Devils can actually smell him as they
drive to meet the main group Subaru asks
about makima tendo hesitates before
saying there's something he wants to
discuss regarding her before they can
though a set of Road spikes are
bizarrely thrown in front of the vehicle
the cast swerves in an attempt to miss
them but runs over the spikes and
crashes in the wreckage Subaru awakens
just in time to see the three American
boys roll it up outside a vehicle sadly
for Subaru and good old Floridian style
the Americans shoot the three Hunters
deep afterwards the Elder two brothers
crack jokes about her but Aldo the
youngest reacts with horror to the
murders now hiding the bodies Sato asks
Joey about his feelings on Kelly with
Joey the anime man stating his only
response to be a mild annoyance and
disgust Sato cracks up laughing before
morphing his face to match their of
corroses the three men then discuss his
voice and how it would sound as Sato
shifts his tone and exit in an attempt
to match shirts back with the main crew
they away within a burger restaurant as
dingy and power eat power offers dingy
who vegetables however kusakabe
interrupts ordering her to finish them
off for her own health the others agree
as dingy forces them into her mouth
power begins to sweat choking down a
mixture of vegetables and vomit just
then the woman from the forest walks
past the table the power and frustration
over what just happened runs outside
causing the rest to follow the woman
sits at a table with tolka revealing
that she'd stabbed dingy three times
with a nail in order to invoke the
cursed evil and that only one more poke
is required she entrusts the final poke
to tolka as she begins to munch into her
Burger though she struggles due to her
numb hand and weak senses she is
delighted by The Experience elsewhere
the violence Fame and cabani walk
outside she thanks him for purchasing
her an ice cream cone then questioning
his role as the violence fiend given his
friendliness he explains that he still
has a lot of his human brain left
meaning that he still holds a lot of his
early human memories however he has no
memories whatsoever of his death only
there he was saved by makimur suddenly a
car pulls up beside them and inside the
American Bad Boy Sato now disguised as
corros gets out he then tells the two to
report tindo and Subaru's death to HQ
before quietly commenting to him himself
on the obvious gullibility the violence
vein cabini and the disguised American
Bad Boy drive over to meet with the main
group American bear boy I'm just saying
that because he's the only like
Westerner I think on this entire show so
far so I'm Gonna Give a listen to some
rip you know what I mean like gunsling
and American bad boy don't worry about
me anyway they tried to eat the rest of
the group Aki speaks will be brother
disguised as crows asking him to
reconsider his place on the mission
however he lies claiming he wishes to
avenge tendo and Subaru as they continue
talking power is distracted by kabini's
car A new typical powerful fashion she
flies into the front seat lying about
having a driver's license and claiming
that the car is actually hers and was
stolen by kabini though kabini quietly
protests it she is silenced by power
chairly threatening her asking as she
wants the car to be washed in her blood
outside the vehicle as the fake Heroes
suspiciously introduces himself to
dinghy trying to be hella touchy and
shake his hand power suddenly bolts the
car forward ramming into both of them
and actually murking the disguised
American as the group all reacts with
horror and power attempts to blame
kabini for the incident kusakabe
suddenly calls out pointing at the
brother's disguise which is now slipping
away revealing its true face Tamaki
recognizes him one in the others of his
contract with his skin devil and the
likelihood of his brothers also being
nearby Archie turns to power who vote
previously panicking and blaming kabini
quickly begins to claim she knew the
truth all along stating that the glory
is all hers while and the car cabani
remains sweating and sobbing in horror
close by two civilians are showing to be
watching the scene in Terror they move
to an Alleyway as not to be seen and it
is revealed that they are the Americans
Joey and Aldo in Disguise Aldo vomits as
Joey attempts to collect himself and
come up with a plan however he is
suddenly pulled around a corner by an
unseen figure and is seemingly rised
Aldo quickly composes himself as Yoshida
a devil Hunter walks around the corner
having swiftly executed Joey noting
eldo's vomit he writes him off as a
bystander and leaves quietly muttering
that a pro wouldn't puke
somewhere in Tokyo a car Rams into
another as one driver leans his head out
to confront the other he's met by Cosmo
who cheerily repeats the phrase
Halloween to him the driver slowly
begins to repeat the phrase to himself
over and over Quan XI appears and begins
leading Cosmo and the other girls in her
group away noticing a sushi restaurant
pingiste grows excited as they enter the
staff Express fear of the group but
begins serving them either way as Cosmo
makes them repeat Halloween too whilst
they wait for their food pingiste
another member of the group begins to
list off facts about fish and long takes
a bite out of a ceramic plate then
stating she is exhausted Kwan Shi
instead decides to hunt dinchi the next
day almost
I think is how you say it properly and
Quan Chi uh like her group's names are
so hard to say like my brain though like
literally cut cope try to say them I try
so hard
the next day in a crowded Street in
Japan the mysterious old German man is
seen touching a passerby on the shoulder
the duty touched then gasps and grabs
out and he passed by next to them and so
forth until the entire Street had linked
itself converting into doll-like
creatures along the way throughout the
cities the four different groups tolka
and her harim Aldo the elderly man and
Quan XI all prepare in various ways to
begin hunting the chainsaw devil
elsewhere any building makima walks
through a cluster of dole-like corpses
she orders beam and Prince to go and
protect denji whilst making the
protection of the other Hunters only a
secondary objective at an apartment
store the creepy old dude watches dingy
and the others through a window from a
distance He commands his dolls to attack
the group once they enter the building
following the party inside the doll's
arms warp into blades however as they
enter through the door kusakabe is
revealed to be crouching inside of a
ritual Circle then using the power of
the stone devil he petrifies the
approaching dolls Yoshida explains the
power of the doll Devil stay seen that
if they touch any part of a person
including the clothes that they wear
they will be transformed into a
subservient doll as Aki suggests that
there would be a limit to the amount
that could be made a large swarm of
dolls instantaneously burst through the
windows charging towards the group as
they run to the second floor power
suddenly grabbed as her and dingy rip
the dolls to Pieces kusakabe reveals
their themes are likely and luckily
immune to the dull Devil's Powers as
more swarm a hunter named Nakamura
suddenly appears summoning the fox devil
to swipe them away bro this guy's
probably gonna die as we know who every
single Fox devil use of this this dude
just leaves when he starts getting
attacked too hard Tamaki explains to
everyone that there were Hunters
stationed in every building and the
street and that the mission's true
purpose was to hunt the Assassin
creating the dolls called Santa Claus
explain meaning that those turned into
dolls can never be restored he notes
that the ability is short-ranged meaning
that the Assassin is then the nearby
vicinity and apologizes to dingy for
using him as bait over with the woman
she sits at a nearby park waiting close
by tolka clutches his nail preparing to
use it on dingy in the bathroom of the
department store Aldo sits psyching
himself up for the coming conflict the
elderly man summons another swarm of
dolls to attack as cabani attempts to
repair the dent in her car and Quan XI
finally appears to hunt
it's just a free for right now I love
this part of the story so much as more
dolls are created by the old man they
begin flowing inside the store dodging
the fox level swipes and lunging forward
Angel summons one of his weapons using
five years worth of his life span that
he had absorbed from humans then strikes
down several of the approaching dolls
when Christian as to why he knew such a
weapon earlier he responds that he has
his reasons outside a group of devil
Hunters appear preparing to Aid the
group however they are haltered by the
appearance of quan XI and uh harim as
they prepare to attack the girls Quan
she pulls out a sword and dashes forward
making her way to the second floor of
the building in almost an instant
dropping in our dented swords she draws
two more as the hunters and dolls are
revealed to have been sliced apart
having seen a vision of the events
through his future site aiki warns the
others as he and the angel devil are
barely able to block her continued
attacks being knocked to the floor
Nakamura who was too slow to react is
decapitated by her barrage I told you
this man would die Quan she then stands
up looking back at a consumed dingy and
power outside members of quan Chi's team
wait destroying the remaining dolls
suddenly they are approached by kashibe
kabini and the violence theme Pincus tea
uses her ability to see that kashibe his
contracts with the needle claw and knife
Devils before assessing him it's
harmless due to his lack of body parts
with which he hasn't already made
contracts kashibe slowly strikes towards
them as they prepare to fight inside the
building Aki's group react to Quan shi's
instantaneous attacks in a Flash she
kicks dingy into the air before knocking
out kusakabe and Tamaki moving towards
Yoshida he summons the octopus devil to
absorb the brunt of the attack before
spraying the rest of the room for the
mist of ink attempting to take it by
surprise Yoshida moves behind Quan Shi
but is quickly knocked down but before
she can kill him kashibe intervenes
having already taken long and pinga
stiha stage orders dingy and power to
restrain the hostages as power reveals
that she was actually just playing dead
the entire time kashibi and kwanxi who
are revealed to actually be past
acquaintances sit down to discuss the
situation kashibe begins to discuss
retirement and old age however as he
speaks he holds up notes in a notepad
that reveal makima is listening to them
through his notepad he promises to give
quanxi freedom in return for helping
kill makima quanxi refuses explaining
through a seemingly unrelated anecdote
that she prefers not to get involved
stay seen their ignorance is bliss as
she says this Aldo enters and shoots at
dinghy kashiba kicks dingy though
causing the attack to miss but long is
still able to take the opportunity to
Grapple him and free herself then in a
Flash both Quan XI and kashibe move to
slice each other's throats after a few
strikes Quan Shi is able to throw
kashibe out of the window but he is able
to slow his Fall by sliding down the
building's estate area and falling atop
of kabini's car Aldo continues to fire
at the various combatants leaping out of
the way of a fireball shot by long
however Quan she grabs them and throws
him through the window as well with him
also falling and landing on kabini's car
inside of the building the Violet spin
continues fighting of a swarm of dolls
ascabini looks down in complete horror
at the state of a destroyed vehicle
power still holding pengusty hostage
demands that quanxi leave her and dinchy
alone Quan Chi politely asks power to
stand down promising her safety which
causes her to hesitate suddenly our boy
beam emerges from the floor knocking
back long and freeing dingy from her
grasp as dingy chooses to flee Quan Shi
is stopped by Yoshida who requests a
rematch the two begin to spar rapidly
dodging one another's blows but still
Landing a few solid hits on one another
Yoshida comments that Quan Shi is likely
not human due to her minimal reaction to
several devastating blows meanwhile
dingy and Ben play with beam advising
him not to waste Blood by turning it
into his chainsaw form as they run dingy
accidentally stands on tolka's nail and
is suddenly whisked into the ear as they
both react with shock and confusion
dingy is ripped apart by the cursed evil
before tolka appears and kicks beam to
the ground as dingy and beam lay
unconscious the woman appears and
applauds tolka's work however ignoring
talker's concerns of moving the body the
woman begins to explain the secrets of
making a perfect doll she says by
gathering the trust respect worship and
pity of an individual over a period of
time before converting them you can make
the perfect doll with that she then
transforms him revealing that she in
fact is the real Santa Claus and that
their elderly man was merely another
perfect doll controlled by her as Aki
and the other Hunters awaken Juan XI
best Yoshida and throws him through a
window as he falls he is able to catch
himself with the octopus devil back
inside side the others prepare to fight
until Aki suddenly stops horrified and
confused by his Future Vision from
outside Santa Claus sacrifices the
elderly man and three children that he
had promised to the hell devil in return
for sending every living person within
the building to hell those inside the
building are all of a sudden plunged
into pitch black darkness as those
outside are horrified to see a giant
six-fingered hand reach down and
seemingly crush the building those who
are inside the building then quickly
appear in a large grassy field where
this Sky completely covered in thousands
of various doors all moving throughout
the year this is hell as the group
survey their surroundings in Hell Aki
kicked stingy awake immediately Digi
reactivatedly begins to transform but is
only able to make the tip of the
Chainsaw appear from his head due to the
fact that he is low on blood Quan Shi
requests say truce among the various
parties whilst they try to figure out
their current situation she turns and
notes that they fiend power long penisty
and violence are all suffering nervous
breakdowns Aki asks the angel devil of
their current situation to watch angel
in an absolutely petrified days explains
that they are in Hell Quan XI asks
pingiste if they have means of an escape
however pingasi frightenly explains that
they are being watched by Devils for
their power far greater than that of the
gun devil the Primal fears whom have
never died in desperation pegasi asks
permission to commit suicide only to
weep as she is refused by Quan XI she
cries out as one of the doors opens and
a black drop of liquid falls out towards
the ground as it does so it symbols the
entrance of the darkness devil the group
rated themselves to fight and his
Darkness surrounds them a row of
bisected astronauts appear and a moment
quicker than light itself the darkness
devil moves past them all detaching each
and every single arm from all of their
bodies each person person reacts with
shock falling to the ground and bleeding
from their exposed wounds as tolka now
fully under Santa Claus's control offers
the darkness devil a proposition
dingey's heart in return for the power
to kill makima now flesh it outside of
Hell Santa Claus receives a small
fragment of the darkness Devil's flesh
then proceeds to swallow it whole as the
darkness devil accepts Santa Claus's
deal it picks up tolka and rips him
apart kusakabe attempts to utilize the
stone Devil's power to fight however the
darkness devil merely grabs the stone
devil and crushes it killing kusakave
while this happens beam using blood from
his Civic arms revives stingy before
being split into Paces by the darkness
evil and killed scene beams corpse Quan
XI and Tamaki prepare to attack however
are also mutilated alongside power long
and pingisty
saying this the Petrified violence fiend
asks kabini to remove his mask he then
attacks with a kick however before he
can hit the darkness devil it speaks in
an unknown language and his body is
blasted with multiple holes dingy now
transformed then lunges to attack but
before he can make contact all of his
bones are crushed and snapped which
makes him crumple to the ground as Aki
observes Powers unconscious body he is
reminded of amino and collapses
muttering I not again I still alive the
violence fan attacks once more but is
impaled by a sick ass looking
Renaissance blade on steroids that are
suddenly summoned by the darkness devil
as the fiend's blood Rains Down The
Darkness devil crouches looming over Aki
as the angel devil looks on too scared
to even move the darkness devil slowly
turns to look at him he then randomly
begins to bleed from his eyes nose and
mouth before collapsing to the floor are
he likewise begins to bleed as the
darkness devil reaches out to touch him
suddenly Prince appears grabbing at the
darkness devil but like all of the
others before she can make contact she
too is absolutely dominated quickly
communicating with markima though
Prince's ordered to Summoner to hell
what she tries to stop but makima
command to her she follows these orders
and makima emerges both her and the
Darkness devil then face each other
quickly snapping their fingers in each
other's directions makima's finger
suddenly snaps as the various mouths of
the darkness devil erupt with blood
makima approaches hulker's body placing
her hand on his decapitated head then
holding her arm out her bones are slowly
twisted and cracked as the darkness
devil summons a sword to impale her as
makima touches his head tolka offers all
of himself to the hell devil in return
for sending them all back just then as
quickly as they all entered they are all
transported back to the rooftop of the
theme park Santa Claus was stationed at
as this happens Santa Claus absorbs her
remaining dolls transforming into a tall
multi-armed creature she begins to
approach makima taunting her while
makima holds dingy's torso and now
having given him some of her blood pulls
his cord she then explains that were the
darkness Devil's flesh no attacks and
the dark will have any effect on her
however makima asks dingy if he will
save her to which he responds having
transformed with an aggressive woof
before charging into battle kashibe and
Yoshida sit outside finishing off the
remaining dolls they discuss makima and
acknowledge that she has some ulterior
motivations to her actions beyond that
of the bureau as kashibe asks whether
she can hear them Yoshida explains that
she currently isn't as none of her
subservience are nearby going on to say
that she can only borrow the ears of
lower life forms such as rats or birds
back on the rooftop denji slices through
Santa Claus's arm angrily yelling at her
about placing power and the others in
danger moving through a shadow Santa
Claus is able to instantaneously heal
himself and blast dingy through the
floor then she gets up lunging at her
but is knocked back by another swarm of
dolls Suga he looks on while clutching
quanchi's seven head then removing her
eye patch and reaching inside of the
socket she Yanks out a Long arrow-like
Blade before dropping the head into the
Swarm attacking denji the dolls are
suddenly torn apart as quanji appears
revived a new hybrid form proving that
she also wasn't human quanji agrees to
fight alongside dingy in order to avenge
long and ping a Steve before suddenly
Vanishing over in a nearby Alleyway
quanxi appears in front of Santa Claus
blasting her with powerful bulbs however
just as quickly as she has torn apart
she heals herself and congratulates Quan
XI on her moniker as the first devil
Hunter wondering how to attack Quan XI
whom is moving at speed she cannot
Register Santa Claus suddenly Returns
the humanity to her dolls restoring
their minds whilst forcing them to
continue the assault as dingy stares at
the now frightened and screaming human
dolls charging towards him he
exasperately shouts there's some real
villain right there now faced with
the emotional human dolls dingy choosers
to run away but his attempts to escape
are blocked and he is forced to impale
one of the dolls with his chainsaw
feeling guilty over this dingy holds
back along with the other dolls to
gradually swarm him suddenly quanxi
appears shooting the remaining dolls to
Pieces she tells dinghy that the dolls
are merely imitating humans dingy asks
how sure she is to what she responds
they're believing it is the only way
he'll be able to bring himself to kill
them reminding him their ignorance is
bliss taking this moment to pause Santa
Claus bursts through a wall and grabs
Quan XI however is once again torn apart
by her blasts looking up Quan Chi
realizes that night has fallen with a
newfound Darkness enhancing Santa
Claus's Powers even further Santa Claus
moves forward and heads stingy towards
the gas station whilst grabbing the
various balls fired by Quan Shi out of
the ear Juan XI turns seeing that Santa
Claus has turned along and pegasi's
corpses into dolls and taken sugahagi
hostage unable to bring herself to fight
them Kwan Shi has is stabbed through the
chest by the pingisty doll which causes
Santa Claus to wonder whether she could
turn Quan XI into a doll as well
suddenly dingy emerges coating himself
in gasoline then raving his chainsaws
together he creates a spark igniting
himself on fire leaping towards a
surprise Santa Claus he begins to tear
into her body as she lets out a series
of pained cries denji and Santa Claus
both arrive in pain as dingy complains
about the heat of his flaming body
pushing him back Santa Claus heals
herself instantly mocking dingy for his
foolishness dingy retort claiming to
watch a great amount of educational
programming before revealing the chain
of his chainsaw to be wrapped around
Santa Claus's body using it to keep
himself close he lunges again slicing
into her she comments on the futility of
his actions as she splits the pain and
damage between her various dolls however
dingy comments that her regeneration has
begun to slow due to the light from his
Flames suddenly Santa Claus slams dingy
and to a wall as a numerous number of
dolls break through and begin stabbing
him in the back Santa Claus then chooses
to wait and watch dingy burn and die
from blood loss calling him machima's
dog however Digi instead tears into the
dolls and drinks their blood to
rejuvenate himself he tries to move
forward only to once again be sworn by
dolls as Santa mockingly tells him that
he will be reunited with makima in death
suddenly dingy begins to pull on his
chain dragging Santa Claus towards him
as he ignores the blows from countless
dolls around him growing more worried
Santa Claus orders her dolls to keep her
away from him pulling against the chain
in a tug of war a pair of dolls and a
car then come speeding around the corner
slamming into dingy and causing a
massive explosion but still dingy
emerges from the wreckage cloaked
entirely in Flames having not stopped
pulling on the chain in shock and horror
Santa Claus questions the extent of his
power and dingy proudly Reveals His
motivation to still be going on the
holiday with Marky Murr hoisting Santa
Claus into the ear denji flings her
towards himself before tearing through
her and ripping her body to Pieces as
she begins to reform dinghy grabs the
remains of the burning car and slams
them down on her causing a second
explosion which rips through her body
turning her into nothing but a
smoldering mess as dingy heals himself
with some of the doll's blood Santa
begins threatening him revealing that
she has armies of dolls stationed across
the entire planet and along with the
power of the darkness devil will be able
to hunt him and everyone he cares about
forever making his life a living hell
but dingy cockingly reminds her of his
immortality before he is suddenly and
surprisingly decapitated by Quan XI
kwanxi then asks Cosmo to use her power
on Santa Claus because while the
conflicts had been going on she was just
wondering around this city on her own
waiting for this moment flashing to
within her own mind Santa Claus suddenly
awakens stay standing inside an endless
Library she sees Cosmo sitting at a
nearby table and comments on the
futility of using psychological attacks
against her due to her mind being linked
to dolls across the world Cosmo looking
up introduces itself as the cosmos Fame
before explaining the extent of her
power the ability to Grant individuals
total and complete understanding of
everything in the universe a process so
overwhelming that the victim is forced
into a semi-conscious state where they
are only able to process the word
Halloween over and over again until the
death as Santa Claus suddenly finds
herself falling through the library her
body is shown in the real world
crumbling to dust as it mutters the word
Halloween over and over Yoshida and
kishibe then arrive as quanxi turns to
fight them silently though the two put
on blindfolds in makima emerges from
between them holding a sword seeing this
Quan Chi instantly surrenders offering
makima anything in return for sparing
the lives of underlings makima doesn't
even listen to her though and ignores
the pleas before quickly slicing all
three of their heads off in one swoop
elsewhere a news anchor reports on the
Dole station throughout the world who
have been locked in sustained Halloween
as a result of the cosmos fiend's power
amongst them Aldo is seen also shuffling
around and repeating Halloween back at
the main location Yoshida removes his
blindfold questioning why casibe doesn't
want to do the same to which he simply
replies that he doesn't want to see a
damn thing
poem so that officially brings us to the
very end of what is pretty much dingy
versus the world or chainsaw man versus
the world as everyone from outside of
Chainsaw man or the countries that are
considered like superpowers outside of
Japan come in and try and take them out
in an attempt to steal chainsaw man and
take him back to their country because
they consider human devil hybrids to be
an extremely important and Powerful
factor in remaining and stay in a
superpower obviously they didn't end up
doing that and there was a lot that went
down throughout this fight with stuff
that's going to be more elaborated on in
future parts of the story that heavenly
moon released yet with especially with
like hell and all of that kind of stuff
as we don't even know what's going on
there the stuff that did drop down like
I just want to reiterate right here was
just a drop of the darkness devil that
was not the full Darkness Devil Himself
here's much much more powerful than that
I would imagine and he would be able to
completely and utterly wipe them out on
this spot he only drop down a dropped
you know like probably Paul makima into
hell in an attempt to try and kill her
there and keep her in Hell or something
I don't know it's just an idea but
anyway you guys have enjoyed this video
and you want to watch more stuff just
like it and get earlier access to these
videos then make sure you check out my
patreon which I will leave down below
but if not obviously then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyway enough of that for now it's been
your professional degenerate diabolo and
I will see you all enable bye